خندق من عدد كبير من الدفاعات التي تمتد
من زابوريجيا الى شبه جزيره القرم هذا ما
كشفته صور للاقمار الصناعيه لاستعدادات
القوات الروسيه للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
الكبير الذي اقترب حسب كييف والذي قد يحدث
في ايه لحظه القوات الروسيه استغلت فصلي
الخريف والشتاء لاعداد دفاعات من خنادق
تسمى في العرف العسكري باسنان التنين
وحقول الغام وحفر مضاده للدبابات
الدبابات التي استلمت اوكرانيا عددا منها
المانيه وبريطانيه وحتى فرنسيه قد
تستخدمها قوات كييف في هذا الهجوم الذي
طال انتظاره
موسكو وعدت منذ اشهر بحرق الدبابات
الغربيه في الارض الاوكرانيه وهي تمتلك
التفوق الجوي الذي يسمح لها بذلك
بصراحه
سيساعدنا ذلك كثيرا لكننا نفهم ايضا انه
لا يمكننا تاجيل الهجوم المضاد ولهذا
السبب سنبدا قبل استلام طائرات اف 16 او
مقاتلات اخرى سنبدا الهجوم ونمضي قدما
بينما في نفس الوقت وهذا مهم جدا نبدا
باستقبال الطائرات الغربيه
كمناشدات وبلود ميرزيلنسكي حلفائه
الغربيين بامداده بطائرات مقاتله كالاف 16
لم تلقى استجابه في واشنطن التي استندت
الى حجه ان مهله تدريب الطيارين ستكون
طويله نظرا لتطور الطائره وتعقيد منظومه
التشغيل والصيانه لكن المراقبين اكدوا ان
على الجيش الاوكراني مجابهه صعاب هائله في
اول اربع وعشرين ساعه في مواجهه الاله
الحربيه الروسيه ولتحقيق اي مكاسب ملموسه
يجب على قواتك ارباك الجنود الروس واختراق
خطوط الدفاع الروسيه لشل منظومه القياده
الميدانيه الروسيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات